these are some of the latest videos in
2022 made by one of the most successful
media creators in recent history
if you take these videos and start
counting the number of cuts per minute
an interesting pattern emerges
the x-axis shows time going up by
minute-long increments while the y-axis
shows the total number of cuts
on its own it might be a bit difficult
to put in perspective but when shown
along with some older videos by the same
channel years ago and as well as some
newer successful and fast growing
channels the developments become clearer
what it shows is that successful videos
are faster than they've ever been before
and why this is has a short answer and a
long answer
the short answer is that our attention
spans are fried monkey-like action and
quick stuff that's the end of the video
the long answer though requires you to
answer a question
how do you build a decentralized video
platform that maximizes exposure to the
highest quality videos possible while
also following a few rules
the monkey you're targeting has limited
time in their day the bottleneck is
demand for content not the supply of it
the monkey has subjective tastes one
monkey's trash is another monkey's
treasure
and the monkey needs to make your
platform money
covering the last one is relatively
speaking simple just let ads ride the
ship of a video for a price
more people make videos that people
watch more money you make
figuring out the other two is more
difficult because it involves something
we call quality which can be quite
obscure and it can also be controversial
to say you're the one that's able to
identify it
on this platform though the proxy for
quality is engagement or more
specifically retention how much of the
viewers time is spent watching a video
a higher number on average a more
successful video
and intuitively this seems reasonable
a good book is one you can't put down
and a good speaker is one who can carry
the audience through a story without
breaking their focus this video was made
possible by nordvpn nord is the vpn i've
personally used for multiple years and
it definitely crossed my mind to just
sit here and talk about why you need to
get a vpn but you know that you need to
get a vpn a lot of you are old or are
getting older and having a dedicated vpn
is just as much a sign of responsible
adulthood as year by year physical
degeneration is i've also decided not to
ramble about how nordvpn is the fastest
vpn even though it is or that it has
nifty features like an automatic kill
switch or threat protection that blocks
ads and web trackers
what i will ramble about though is that
nordvpn's design is the best i mean look
at it from the icon to the subtle
pastels to the clean much superior dark
mode nordvpn is undeniably the alpha of
vpn design and if you follow the link
below you can get 30 days just to admire
that design and you can get a money back
guarantee what you're looking at now is
a retention curve for a youtube video
the higher the amount of people watching
for longer the higher the likelihood
your video will be recommended to users
now there are a dozen other factors
determining a video's success like the
relevance of the content for that
specific person or the success of the
video's marketing but after someone has
carefully engineered a picture that will
make you click on the video the race for
retention begins
the producer hopes that the viewer goes
as far as they can
because a loss of focus is a loss for
them
but this is how the problem emerges when
a measure becomes a target it ceases to
be a good measure the most successful
videos are no longer the most aesthetic
instructive and reflective but the most
attention-grabbing
but maybe we shouldn't be too hasty
critiquing the attention spans of newer
generations is an old tactic and it's
always been more convenient for me to
say that my essay filled with
incomprehensible jargon and breaking at
the seams of tomes and moral superiority
is actually incredibly high quality but
it's those other lowbrow content
producers that are the reason for why no
one reads it
so the real concern is not that
engagement shouldn't belong in our
calculations of quality but it's that
empty engagement calories can exhaust
our ability to pay attention creating a
positive feedback loop which ends up
breaking the correlation between
retention and quality
of course some researchers have grumpily
criticized this connection to begin with
the convincing counterpoint goes that it
may not be the internet that causes the
reduction in attention spans it's just
that those who choose the internet over
reading in a cafe for example may have a
reduced attention span to begin with but
there are others that say not so fast
one study looked at tweets and they
found that over time popular hashtags
have grabbed the public conscience for
less and less time which would seem to
indicate that the public's attention on
specific issues are more likely to fade
now years after we become used to the
internet than it would have faded when
society was just starting to get
adjusted to it and this observation
applies across platforms bursts and
attention with quicker falls thereafter
but maybe you've already started getting
impatient with me thinking man i don't
need a study to validate that my
attention is getting fried i've already
started looking at the comments while
you're talking
so let's do something a bit more
engaging
think of it as a game
again you have contestants that are
competing for viewers because attention
is scarce and also again the contestants
know that retention is one of the
largest factors that will guarantee
their success
if you were playing what would be the
strategy you'd use to win
think about a movie you saw in the
cinema that you loved you may be heard
about a release date and you started to
get excited you intentionally catered
your experience just for the moment that
you began watching
you sat down and you soaked in
everything that you'd been waiting for
it was well paced exciting and it
carried you
just one temporary beautiful moment of
awareness and that over stimulated
monkey brain of yours
and then we have what you're on now
where the quantity is without limits and
if you watch vertically you already have
other stimulus calling for you to go
deeper
and that brings us back to the game we
have millions of players and they
compete for limited space on that square
now maybe you could optimize for the
slow burn and the feeling of wonderment
that a movie like the one you love
provides
maybe for some it could be a successful
strategy
but you could also decide to optimize
purely for the metric the game is about
maybe your video was slow and you see
that the biggest drop off was after one
long shot so next time a long piece of
footage comes around you cut it so that
people can get a little jab and reminder
to keep their eyes on the video
your retention goes up so the video
earns its space on the square and space
on the square means a higher likelihood
to capture attention
but remember or better yet just forget
there are others in this game and they
begin to see what you're doing too and
they see that speed is an answer and so
the spiral begins each video nudging the
number of cuts further and further and
before you know it what would have
seemed a bit much five years ago has
suddenly become the norm
evolution by attention selection
survival of the clippiest
now dramatics aside i want to also be
clear that i am not above attention
grabbing i'm still someone that uses
video views as a form of validation for
the fact that i didn't pursue
engineering or something and i hook
viewers in by coming close to the side
of unnecessary provocation of probably
one of the best media philanthropists on
the planet
and i am also someone that decides to
lean heavily on visuals in many cases at
the cost of fully fleshed out scripts
because it's more likely to keep people
watching and lets me get away with
telling you what you already know
monkeys like 3d animation so this monkey
will make more 3d animation
so please take what i say with a grain
of salt i can be wrong and i will be
wrong and i wouldn't take anyone that
takes themselves too seriously seriously